monsieur raymond barre a donc fait acte
de candidature ce matin à lyon plus que
la nouvelle en soi qui ne faisait aucun
doute pour personne depuis de nombreux
mois c'était la forme qui intéressait
les observateurs et le contenu de la
déclaration car il fallait faire court
et clair et toute la presse était réunie
à 11 heures au palais des congrès de
lyon voici donc la déclaration de
monsieur bart
mes chers compatriotes
depuis des années
je vous rends cours je vous écoute je
dialogue avec vous
un lien s'est créé entre nous
dans trois mois vous choisirez un
nouveau président
vous le ferez dans une période difficile
vous voyez mal l'avenir vous êtes dans
le doute
le chômage continue à frapper
l'économie française ne crée plus
d'emplois
c'est un fait
pendant le septennat qui s'achève la
france a reculé par rapport à ces
complots
et pourtant les forces du renouveau sont
en
notre jeunesse est dynamique et
généreuse
nos entreprises avec leurs cadres leurs
employés leurs ouvriers s'ouvre à la
compétition internationale
nous sommes à la croisée des chemins
si votre choix
devait conduire au retour du système
socialiste dont vous ne pouvez oublier
les erreurs ni les échecs
après le recul
viendrai le déclin
ne sous-estimé pas l'enjeu
je ne me résigne pas pour ma part au
déclin de mon pays il est temps de
mettre fin au faux semblants il est
temps de prendre un nouveau départ
c'est pourquoi
j'ai décidé d'être candidat à la
présidence la république
à l'origine de cette décision il y a
avant tout la confiance que beaucoup
d'entre vous me témoignez
vous me connaissez
comme tout le monde j'ai mes qualités et
mes défauts
mais je ne suis pas un spécialiste de la
virevolte
je n'ai jamais fardée la réalité j'ai
toujours agi avec loyauté
je suis un homme d'ouverture
je n'ai pas l'esprit le parti je veux un
état impartial au service de tous
si vous m'accordez votre confiance
nous traiterons ensemble les questions
essentielles
daudet pan de notre avenir et l'avenir
de nos enfants
la vitalité de la famille la qualité de
l'éducation
le renouveau de la recherche de la
technologie
le poids des impôts
la garantie de la protection sociale le
drame
de la pauvreté et de la solitude
nous devons faire de la france un pays
solide
à ce niveau de salaire et d'emploi
élevés à monnaies fortes
ensemble nous travaillerons pour que
notre vieux pays de liberté renforce sa
cohésion par la solidarité par la
justice et qu'il retrouve le sens
profond
civisme et du patriotisme
ensemble nous ferons de la france
l'artisan d'une véritable union
économique
monétaire
et politique de l'europe
à cet instant
je pense à mes rencontres avec
les françaises et des français de la
métropole
de l'outre-mer et de l'étranger
je pense à mon île natale la réunion
je pense à cette ville d'où je vous
parle à lyon qui m'a élu
mad récente à chacune et à chacun
d'entre vous jeudi
il est temps de faire confiance à la
france et aux français
si vous le voulez ensemble nous ferons
une france forte et fraternelle